so what I want to do here is make a
video about Luke Cage and what I'm
hoping is that at the end of all this
you'll have a strong understanding of
his character as well as why he's being
introduced into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe along with Jessica Jones
so Luke Cage first appeared in 1972 with
Hero for Hire issue number one and was
created by writer Archie Goodwin and
artist John Romita senior now the
appearance of Luke Cage in comics is
extremely important for one major reason
while he was preceded by heroes like
Gabriel Jones as one of Nick Fury's
Howling Commandos Sam Wilson is falcon
and black panther Luke Cage was the
first black hero to receive his own solo
series and Marvel Comics the reason why
is because he came in Marvel's attempt
to capitalize on the concept of
blaxploitation in the early 1970s
following the conclusion of the civil
rights movement in America because
african-americans had received equal
rights a kind of Hollywood Renaissance
took place and that the blaxploitation
movement arose in an effort to create a
singular african-american film and media
culture while these were largely
low-budget due to the fact that movies
were usually written directed in cast by
African Americans films like shaft
Blacula Cleopatra Jones and Superfly all
went towards creating a niche for the
african-american community within the
film industry as such Marvel was looking
to reel in the african-american
community but keep existing fans
satisfied by maintaining Sam Wilson's
position alongside Captain America and
creating a character who could reflect
societal struggles of blacks in America
but also stand on his own two feet in
terms of his own stories so in his first
appearance with euro for hire number one
the beginning of the story serves to
provide us with an understanding of the
situation regarding life in prison and
its various levels of corruption before
transitioning to the origin story itself
initially Luke Cage is depicted as an
inmate in seagate prison off the coast
of Georgia but also has the respect of
the other inmates after having
previously been sent to solitary
confinement for fighting when he's
released by a guard named Court the
indication here is that the two share
extreme animosity towards one another
while we're not told why this is for the
most part we could probably go as far as
to argue that it may be racially
motivated however once he's released and
travels out into the yards he has a
sit-down with a man named shades what we
learn here is that the prison is
expecting the arrival of a new warden
but because the existing leadership
seems to let the prisoners take care of
their own problems without intervening
shades is under the belief the warden
will ruin this idea by restoring order
and law to the prison as a result he
intends to rally the other black
prisoners together for the
purpose of causing a riot on the wardens
first day thereby demonstrating his
inability to control his own prison and
attempt to get him fired
however because Luke Cage command so
much respect from the other inmates
unless he agrees to rally them together
no one will make a move now when Luke
Cage stage that shade seems to have
taken it upon himself to speak for all
the african-americans in the prison one
of his friends named Comanche insults
cage by accusing him of being an Uncle
Tom which is to say acting's have
Servian to the white leaders of the
prison attending to intimidate cage by
threatening him with bodily harm cage
punches Comanches teeth out stating that
he has no intention of being used by
anyone now this is particularly
important in something that I'd like you
to remember because what we'll see as we
go through the rest of this video is
that while cage will form alliances with
other superheroes and even lead teams in
the end cage is very much ok with being
completely alone and so witnessing the
events unfolding court makes the case
that captain Rackham erases prison
guards serving as the interim head of
the prison until the warden arrives has
a legitimate case to throw cage back in
the hole again however instead Rackham
has cage brought to his office now the
reason for this is shown to be due to
the fact that after witnessing the
conversation and subsequent scuffle
between Luke Cage and shades Rocket has
come to the belief that shades is
planning something presenting cage with
a proposition that would have him acting
as a snitch and that he wants Kage to
inform on the actions of the
african-american members of the present
and provide Rackham with their goings-on
and plans cage turns us off her down and
even goes as far as to refuse to shake
Rackham's hand
now while this act doesn't seem big in
and of itself in truth it's actually
huge the reason why is it among men the
refusal to shake another man's hand is
both a sign of disrespect but also an
indication that you have the position
that you're better than them while this
may be the same case for women although
I'm unsure the gesture does not go
unnoticed by Rackham who has Luke aid
sent back to solitary confinement
however rather than being sent there for
a period of time Rackham gives court the
authority to physically assault cage now
the fight between the two is of
stupendous importance here because this
will go towards shaping the perspective
of cage in future stories because Court
is a prison guard cage refuses to
assault him back and instead deals with
the brutalizing situation the reason why
is that for cage the best insult he can
give to court isn't through speech or
physically fighting back
but by constantly taunting court what
this does is make or doubt to be a
failure in that while has actions have
the intention of breaking cages spirit
he's ultimately unsuccessful is cage
simply refuses to give in
despite the viciousness of the attack
furthermore cage taking the higher
ground goes towards the respect the
other prisoners have for him and that
despite at all cages refusal to
acquiesce it makes him strong in both
body and spirit and so with the various
guards pulling court off of cage due to
the faculties lost control and is simply
attacking cage out of anger the scene is
met with the arrival of the new warden
witnessing court both taunting cage and
stating that he intends to do everything
he can to make his life as miserable as
possible
the warden fires court on the spot and
rather than dismissing him from the
premises immediately instead locks him
in a cell with cage instructing the
guards to keep the door locked for 10
minutes Luke Cage sabers the opportunity
to treat court to a full-course meal
composed of knuckles and elbows now
picking up with the wardens arrival at
the office of Rackham rather than
turning around and greeting the warden
Rackham assumes the court has re-entered
the room congratulating court on his
actions of being caged the warden speaks
up stating that his intention to arrive
early and unannounced which for the
purpose of catching the prison staff
off-guard and seeing exactly how the
places ran removing Rackham from his
position is captain rather than firing
him as he did with court the warden
gives Rackham the opportunity to
demonstrate his confidence as an
employee at Sea Gate by working as a
guard and following the appropriate
security measures from here the story
transitions back to Luke Cage and
provides us with the origin of his
character receiving a visit from a man
named dr. Burstein Luke cages physically
examined regarding his injuries but
Burstein also dropped some indications
that he wants to work with cage while
this is initially ambiguous what he says
is that he started a science project of
sorts with the purpose of using a man of
unique skillsets to see it to its
fruition again where this is the only
information we get at the moment the
interview between Burstein and cage
brings us his full backstory what we're
told here is that as a child Luke Cage
had grown up on the streets of Harlem
because of life that he had led require
doing whatever it took to survive cage
and others had engaged in illegal
activities of thieving and hustling in
order to get by forming a friendship
with a man named Willis Stryker as a to
grew older their actions became more and
more extreme
Marvel doesn't really say it the
indication here seems to be the Cajun
striker may have engaged in murder on a
couple of occasions but during their
time together they each developed a
special set of skills Stryker became
exceptional at using throwing knives
while Luke Cage became unbeatable in a
fistfight however where Luke found
satisfaction in his life as a con artist
and a thief
striker pursued a life of high-end crime
including racketeering which is when
criminals run illegal businesses like
underground gambling rings or embezzle
money meaning that they steal from the
company furthermore while the two had
never really been in competition before
all of that changed when they met a
woman named Reva because the fast life
of Stryker allowed for a lot of money to
be made in a short amount of time he was
able to provide Reva with lavish things
like clothes and the nightlife but
because he had given no thought to his
actions outside of making money Stryker
was visited by two men from a rival gang
called the syndicate
what we learned here is that strikers
expansion of his criminal empire saw him
moving in on the turf of the syndicate
and while they had previously warned him
to back off
Stryker chose to ignore them attend me
to leave to the side door with Riva to
avoid the hired muscle strikers met with
the henchmen of the syndicate who
figured his plan and Lydon wait after
beating him up Riva made a break for it
running to Luke Cage for help because
Cage considered himself to be a man of
honor while he and Stryker were rivals
when it came to Riva in the end the two
were still friends and had been through
too much to throw it all away over their
affections regarding a woman coming to
the aid of his friend and pummeling the
hired muscle due to his fighting skill
cage and Riva take Stryker to an
abandoned building for the night at the
same time Riva expresses her concern
over being put in danger and the fact
that she could have lost her life or
worse during strikers altercation with
the men now the problem came into play
when Stryker had recovered from his
injuries at which point Riva had stated
that the fast life he was leading would
only lead to ruin as a result Stryker
blamed Luke Cage claiming that he had
put the moves on his girlfriend and
turned her against him and so the
friendship between the two had ended
sending them down their own separate
ways and Stryker went about his life in
crime while Luke Cage and Riva formed a
relationship leading to the possibility
of marriage between the two however at
some point Stryker had used his
influence to plant drugs in the home of
Luke Cage and then informed the police
leading the cages arrest and so as a
result cage was thrown in prison and
Strucker went back to seeing Riva
now following this because Strucker was
still involved in his life of crime all
of it came to a head when the syndicate
grew tired of Stryker moving in on their
turf and ordered a hit attacking Stryker
and leading to a highway chase during
the conflict the syndicate fire on his
car sitting it off a cliff resulting in
the death of Riva from being shot with
Stryker surviving the crash
and so after bringing this story to a
close cage reveals that the reason why
he's able to keep his sanity despite
constantly being tortured by the guards
is that his sole motivation is to prove
his innocence and escape the prison in
order to get his revenge on Stryker now
after hearing all of this the situation
of Luke Cage here is actually not unlike
Captain America what I mean here is that
the drive of Steve Rogers was to prove
himself worthy of being a soldier to
fight on the front lines of world war ii
against the oppression of the germans
while this situation of Luke Cage is
devoid of a wartime situation in and of
itself the fact remains that on his face
his drive to defeat Stryker may be about
revenge but I would go as far as to
argue that it's more about self
vindication but regardless of his
motives due to his personal drive his
skills in combat and self-reliance dr.
Burstein comes to the conclusion that
Luke Cage is the best candidate for the
experimental program however for Luke
Cage
aside from Riva all he's known as
cruelty at the hands of humanity and so
as a result his idea is to simply blow
off Burstein in favor of finding his own
path to freedom rather than subjecting
himself to an experimental procedure in
the hopes that the parole board may look
highly upon it in the end though for
cage the possibility of being granted
parole and getting his revenge on
Stryker is too good of an opportunity to
pass up especially considering the fact
that his previous fights in the prison
combined with the testimony of the
corrupt guards would make his attempt to
gaining freedom virtually impossible and
so seeing no other choice the following
day he meets with dr. Burstein as we're
told the equipment being used in the
experiment was purchased using a
research grant from Stark Industries and
the purpose of burstiness research is to
test whether or not a bath in the
unidentified chemicals will aid in
eliminating disease from an infected
person in addition to granting eternal
youth however because Luke Cage has no
illnesses Burstein states that his
intention is to infect cage with an
unidentified disease now the situation
the cage faces here is that the disease
is lethal as is the only way to verify
the Cure works meaning that if it
doesn't
faces the prospect of losing his life on
the other hand willingly subjecting
himself to an experiment that may kill
him but it's designed for the benefit of
humanity would ultimately make him a
hero in the eyes of the parole board
which would increase his chances of
freedom and so after taking the
injection and entering the liquid the
scene is met with the arrival of Rackham
who had relieved the guard outside of
the lab since the doctor had left taking
his revenge on cage by fiddling with the
chemical mixture in the hopes it would
kill him
once the doctor returns the situation
devolves into complete chaos with a
chemical mixture swirling around cage
while the doctor tries to subdue Rackham
and bring the experiment to an end Luke
Cage is able to break free of his
confines because Rackham panics due to
his failed attempt to kill cage and
knowing that he would most likely be
killed in turn where his initial
reaction is to shoot him cage reacts by
literally backhanding Rackham to death
faced with the prospect of having
possibly killed a prison guard which
would destroy his chances of being
granted parole Luke Cage lashes out and
in the process smashes a hole in the
prison wall realizing that he has super
strength
and knowing that if Rackham is dead that
he would be given the death sentence for
capital crime cage smashes his way
through a wall and escapes the prison
however because the prison is on an
island there really isn't anywhere for
cage to go and so rather than being
given the death sentence for his
presumed murder of Rackham he picks up a
rock with the intention of fighting the
guards because of this one of the guards
mistakes the rock for a gun and in the
process unloads a hail of bullets with
the others joining in believing that
there's reason to shoot and so falling
into the water below cage comes to the
realization that in addition to
super-strength his skin is as hard as
steel making it impenetrable to bullets
in addition to this because the gars
discovered his clothes riddled with
bullet holes the assumption is a cage
has been shot to death and simply fell
into the water below as a result he was
simply presumed dead with his case file
being closed out and so as the origin
comes to a close Kate's travels back to
Harlem with the intention of using his
newfound abilities to track down Stryker
and take his revenge so following this
origin story Heroes for Hire was
released as a bi-monthly series with
Archie Goodwin staying on board for the
first four issues depicting Luke Cage is
quite literally a Hero for Hire so long
as those who contracted him could afford
his price the main focus of the story
removed Luke Cage from the
larger-than-life conflicts of the
Avengers and the Fantastic Four and
sted kept him on the street level within
the first four issues Archie Goodwin had
cage set up the Heroes for Hire business
and an office above Jim Theatre which
served as a Marvel Comics stand-in for
the Apollo Theater in Times Square but
also took the character of Stryker and
transformed him into cages Arjun emesis
of Diamondback because a series saw
relative success with its initial launch
efforts were made to raise the profile
of Luke Cage by crossing them over with
more popular characters from Marvel but
also establish his own rogues gallery
who had faced off against within his own
series to this in issues three four and
five under Archie Goodwin saw the
introduction of small-time villains
Gideon mace phantom of the 45th Street
and black Mariah none of whom were
considered to be powerful villains but
all of whom would face off against Cage
using their own respective skill set now
with issue number 5 Goodwin left the
comic to help Marvel launch the tomb of
Dracula series as well as create Jessica
drew the Spider Woman and so as a result
he was replaced by Steve Englehart
because Englehart had demonstrated his
ability to tell successful stories with
a series of titles under his belt
including Iron Man number 45 Sgt fury
and his Howling Commandos number 97 be
Incredible Hulk number 152 and journey
into mystery volume 2 issue number 1
Marvel editor-in-chief Roy Thomas was
looking to bring Englehart in as a way
to continue the successful recipe of
Goodwin but also expand on luke cage's
character within Marvel as a whole in
addition to this because Marvel was
moving towards more of a racially
diverse comic line Englehart expanded
the rows gallery of cage to include
Hispanic villains senior Mort a Native
American villain Lion Fang in addition
to the return of shades and Comanche
from its time during incarceration at
Sea Gate prison furthermore in an effort
to bolster cages popularity in
mainstream comics he was for hire issue
number nine saw cage teaming up with the
Fantastic Four in an effort to recoup
money owed by Doctor Doom for contract
at Luke Cage and carried out while many
of these stories found themselves to be
wildly popular among african-american
fans in the inner city due to the fact
that Luke cages battles could have taken
place right outside their doors as a
blaxploitation era began to wane so too
two cages popularity because of
blaxploitation movement had as many
supporters as itted critics and that
some viewed it as a way to empower black
americans while others believe that it
promoted black stereotypes between 1974
1979 organizations like the nat
Association for the Advancement of
Colored People also known as the
n-double-a-cp
the Christian Leadership Conference and
the National Urban League all work
together for the purpose of dismantling
the blaxploitation genre as a result by
issue number 14 and 1974 Englehart had
left this series to focus on as one of
the Avengers with cages comics being
handed over to Tony Isabella which
lasted until issue number 16 at which
point the series was cancelled and
relaunched his power man with the
numbering continuing at issue number 17
following this the stories of Luke Cage
under his Power Man alias achieved the
popularity Marvel was looking for due to
the fact that he was now operating as a
superhero under the same mantra as the
rest of Marvel's lineup rather than an
outlier working on the fringes of the
superhero community in addition to this
cages popularity was bolstered even
further when wine will discourage rover
to operate as part of the superhero team
the defenders created by writer Roy
Thomas and originally appearing in
Marvel feature number 1 in December of
1971 following a three-part crossover
and Doctor Strange number 183 member the
Submariner number 22 and The Incredible
Hulk number 170 unlike the Avengers who
fought threats to the planet Earth the
defenders were street-level and commonly
dealt with villains who were too weak
for the Avengers to worry about but too
strong for anyone defenders member to
beat on their own because of defenders
base at the time consisted of Brunhilde
a member of the Asgardian warrior race
called the Valkyrie with the same powers
as Thor - his hammer Nighthawk a man
with super strength speed durability
reflexes and senses in addition to
Doctor Strange and the Hulk Cage found
another boost in popularity as fans of
the series who either had no knowledge
of him or no interest in him found him
thrown onto the team as a result with
the defenders being so popular Marvel
brought Cage into another team-up with
Marvel two-in-one number 13 by Robert
Slifer which saw Ben Grimm and Luke Cage
coming together against the genetic
experiment called Brigadoon now at the
same time that this was happening
Marvel was coping with another character
who was struggling with poor sales Danny
ran the iron fist was part of Marvel's
efforts to capitalize on the rising
popularity of kung-fu movies and Eastern
culture in the mid-1970s however because
iron fist stories were as much about
mysticism as they were about martial
arts his first solo series only lasted
about 15 issues with Lin wine Doug mink
Tony Isabella and Chris
Clairmont all writing for the series
much like DC's Green Lantern and green
arrow
during the 1970s by Neil Adams and
Dennis O'Neil Marla took the step of
attending to Sal there's a Luke Cage and
Iron Fist publications by bringing the
two together relaunching the Power Man
line a third time and rolling Danny Rand
in under Chris Claremont the comic was
retitled Power Man and Iron Fist
consider to be the most notable run of
both characters time and Marvel and a
fan favorite and truth while Claremont
had engineered the crossover of the two
titles resulting in the combination into
one it wasn't until the arrival of Mary
Joe Duffy that the series became popular
because Claremont was writing for
uncanny x-men at the time along with
John Byrne his artist the task of
launching a team title between Luke Cage
and iron fists was virtually
unmanageable due to the complex nature
of the stories within the x-men
franchise as a result where Mary Joe
Duffy found success in Marvel with
stories like Ron the space knight Duffy
was transferred to the Power Man Iron
Fist title due to her success with wrong
while many of the Marvel stories at the
time saw a darker shift in storytelling
following the death of Gwen Stacy in
1971 Duffy kept the Power Man Iron Fist
comic light-hearted and entertaining
with very few fight scenes and instead
focused heavily on the friendship
between the two by providing constant
banter as a result the back and forth
between Kage and Rand led to a massive
boost and popularity which shows the
efforts of Duffy even further because
Claremont x-men was a Golden Goose of
marvel at the time with focus being
emphasized on the interpersonal
relationships of the characters in
providing their day-to-day lives the
formula was replicated by Duffy who
provided readers with a day in the life
of style of stories in each comic
however where Duffy's approach was
successful in terms of sales at the time
Marlowe was pushing for darker stories
across the board as a result Duffy was
removed from her position as writer and
replaced by Kurt Busiek as a younger
writer looking to make his bones in the
industry music was initially hired as a
fill-in writer for issues 89 to 93 and
following his success was brought on as
the main writer of the series however
much like Duffy music prefer the
light-hearted tone of the stories with
his writing style actually influenced by
Duffy herself and so like Duffy after
only six issues Marvel terminated their
contract with music who went on to write
for the Green Lantern series following
this the Power Man Iron Fist title fell
into disarray for the next
so let's Marvel brought in a series of
interim writers singin to the stories
including Steve grant Richard Howell and
Archie Goodwin leading up to Jim owlsley
taking over with issue number 111
leading to the death of iron fist
storyline and the cancellation of the
Power Man Iron Fist Heroes for Hire
series now in 1992 following the removal
of Jim shooters editor-in-chief with Tom
DeFalco taking over because the early
nineties saw a rise and the popularity
of fast paced high-octane comics Luke
Cage was returned to his own solo series
simply titled cage picking up after the
events of Power Man Iron Fist under mark
Maclaurin the story focus on cages
transition to Chicago in the end though
this series only lasted for about 20
issues the reason why is because the
element of Luke Cage that made him
relevant had long since been gone what I
mean here is a society and comic book
fans had moved away from the mindset of
paying special attention to the rarity
of a black hero with their own title
this was especially compounded on by the
fact of the x-men The Avengers and other
groups both major and minor had their
own multicultural lineups as a result
Luke Cage standing as a street-level
criminal required that he go toe-to-toe
with anti heroes like The Punisher who
had been gaining popularity due to his
no-holds-barred do whatever it takes to
kill all criminals attitude and so while
writer Mark Maclaurin did what he could
to revitalize interest in this series by
resurrecting Danny Rand revealing that
the previous version killed was a
doppelganger as well as reinstating
Heroes for Hire
the comic fell to the wayside in the
face of irrelevance after this in 1997
under John Ashe rinder who was known for
his 1987 reboot and successful runs of
The Suicide Squad in DC Comics Marvel
tried their hand at bringing Luke Cage
and iron fists back together with Heroes
for Hire volume 2 as fallout from the
onslaught saga would saw the presumed
deaths of the Avengers and the Fantastic
Four the second volume of Heroes for
Hire picked up this flack by bolstering
their ranks to include Deadpool she-hulk
Black Knight Jim Hammond the original
Human Torch Scott Lang and white tiger
all of whom who functioned in the same
manner as the original Power Man Iron
Fist team and that they took contracts
to do with credible threats and
criminals however because the sales of
this comic were low the series only
lasted for 19 issues before again it was
canceled at this point we jump to 2001
with Brian Michael Bendis creation of
Jessica Jones
as part of the Marvel max imprint which
focus on more adult-oriented material
the story served as a retcon of sorts to
cover the time when Luke Cage was not
present on Marvel Comics with a series
follow Jessica Jones at her time as a
private investigator Luke cages
involvement in the beginning of the
series was more of a sexual interest for
Jones and that the two were on-again
off-again lovers however his role as a
supporting character came during the
storyline purple which sought Bend is
expanding on the history between purple
man and Jessica Jones during this time
cage was depicted as a caring and
nurturing boyfriend who provided a
crutch for Jones to use as she coped
with confronting kilgrave at the request
of the family members of victims now by
2004 following the cancellation of the
Avengers title with Avengers
disassembled under Brian Michael Bendis
the chaotic appearances of Luke Cage
came to an end with a launch of new
Avengers using the first six issues to
introduce us to recall the raft which
saw electro being contracted to free the
prisoners of the super human prison off
the coast of New York with Kage arriving
as one of the heroes attempting to
corral the villains back in he was
approached by Steve Rogers to join the
new roster of the Avengers alongside
Wolverine Iron Man Spider Woman and
spider-man staying on as a member of the
team for the next five years during the
events of 2006 is civil war the New
Avengers are temporarily disbanded in
light of the fact that the superhero
community is split on the idea of
registration where Jessica Jones
retreats to Canada and away from the
conflict within the United States Luke
Cage stays behind fighting alongside
Steve Rogers and his Secret Avengers
furthermore following Civil War the
assassination of Steve Rogers and for
the duration of the New Avengers title
leading up to 2010 cage should reform
the team alongside spider-man Spider
Woman iron fist and Wolverine with a
group largely operating underground
avoiding the attempts of shield to
capture them and attempt to subvert the
efforts of shield and the registration
movement however by 2010 following the
events of siege and the elimination of
superhuman Registration New Avengers vol
2 began as a monthly series and under
the banner of the heroic age which
sought to remove the stories away from
their daughter themes Bendis wrote the
group being led by Luke Cage and
consisting of Victoria hand iron fist
Jessica Jones Mockingbird Carol Danvers
spider-man Ben Grimm and Wolverine
because the main Avengers had reformed
during this time the New Avengers were
the other half of the
coin and the sense that the Avengers
operated out of stark tower while the
New Avengers operated out of the rebuilt
Avengers mansion with both groups
operating to protect the world Luke Cage
remained the leader of the team until
issue number 34 which saw Jessica Jones
leaving in order to raise her child away
from the constant battles with criminals
and villains prompting Luke Cage to
travel with her disbanding the New
Avengers and so with the events leading
up to Secret Wars an all-new
all-different marvel Luke Cage had
returned to his life as a superhero by
forming a branch-off group of the
Avengers called the Mighty Avengers
originally created by Carol Danvers
during the time between Civil War and
the elimination of superhero
registration during siege Mighty
Avengers vol 2 under Luke Cage was
composed of blue Marvel Adam Brashear
spectrum Ronan white tiger Falcon
she-hulk and the new Power Man
Victor Alvarez with a group functioning
as pro bono heroes working for charity
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and hopefully
you have a pretty good understanding
about Luke Cage now and with that being
said I will catch you guys later peace